this morning in an exclusive interview
we are hearing from azrael cleary one of
the r kelly survivors who testified
against him in court now on monday as
you know kelly was found guilty on
federal racketeering and sex trafficking
charges he could face life in prison now
this is not the first time that we spoke
with asriel clary we also talked to her
back in 2019 in a very different
interview she was still living with r
kelly and another woman joycelyn savage
at the time now they both defended kelly
and said they were his girlfriends here
is part of that interview
what is your relationship both of you
with with with our kelly
we're with him
we're with him yeah that's what it is
and we're in a relationship with him
a very
a very strong relationship they said
both women claim kelly was not abusive
and we should note that r kelly was
nearby and made his presence known to
the women during that interview although
we did not know that he was still in the
room we were told that he had left we
sat down with azrael clara yesterday
more than two years later she says our
conversation back then was a turning
point for her
i look back at the interview that we did
originally
and i'm wondering how you go from
that young woman
who was very clear then i have no
judgment here i'm just trying to
understand your process
it was consensual she was in love with
him she felt he cared about her to
making the decision to take the stand
against him i feel like
that uh interview was a blessing because
you know like i said you know
for five years since i was 17 i didn't
have any relationships
with any other woman except for women
that he had been intimate with and so
when
i did that interview with you
i instantly regretted
immediately how i reacted
and um
you did you regretted it i did and i i
don't know something about just watching
you be very casual and calm and
collected and it just reminded me of me
i was like wait a minute i used to be
that poise i used to be that calm you
know what happened to that girl where
did she go
and i you know after that interview when
we went back to trump towers i knew that
he knew that by seeing you it has
shifted something in me really
shifted to what
it kind of made me kind of wake up in a
sense and and realize
why am i acting like this why am i
putting myself through all of this
misery
why am i
exploiting myself for a man who
has me in this position in the first
place you know and i really had to come
to terms and you know realize that it
wasn't love
it you know love doesn't hurt you know
that was a question everybody was asking
at the time it was it was really
remarkable to see her years later i had
more of our interview with asriel clary
she shares what happened before and
right after the interview back in 2019
and what made her realize she had to
finally leave